Let's write the null and alternative hypothesis in statistical symbols. For the
null, we use a capital H with a subscript 0 to indicate the null hypothesis. We
put a colon to show that what comes after is the null hypothesis. We use mu
subscript program to indicate what the average amount spent per week on food
would be if we could implement this whole program throughout the entire co-op.
What we're saying here is that if we implemented this new program, the average
amount of money spent per week on food by the co-op members would be either
equal to 151, the original population mean, or greater. In other words, there
will be no improvement. Now, let's write the alternative. We have some H, the
subscript A for alternative hypothesis. I'll write alt over here to remind us
that that's what it is. We have a colon in the right place. We input the value
of the population parameter. If we could go to all co-op members and give them
this mu program, what would their average cost be per week? And we hope there
will be a reduction, so we'll write less than 151. Be sure to write these down
on your sheet of paper.